[Music]
if you've had enough of covered in
politics
thank god there's the football spectator
economist rod little has been watching
the euros 2021
and blogging daily for the spectator on
coffee house with his observations
who he's cheering for and which
commentators get on his nerves
rod welcome back to spectator tv so
talk us through your highlights so far
wales
without question i think they've been a
revelation um and
there's a misapprehension about wales as
well which is which is basically that
they're plucky underdogs you know
and one hopes that they do well but one
doesn't hold out very much expectation
for them
as it happens they're one of the more
talented teams in the tournament you
know they've got people
uh there's down to danny james for
example gareth bale we all know about
aaron ramsey
but also i mean they're able to bring on
from the bench a player of the uh worth
of
uh of david brooks of bournemouth
absolutely brilliant young player
there's a lot of skill there and you
know they hammered the turks
you wouldn't have known me to listen to
the commentary
because poor robbie savage was having a
fit he was very very nervous
but in fact the turks never came
anywhere near them
it was a thoroughly deserved victory uh
and they've got a good draw against a
very
good swiss team and they're through to
the next round so it's terrific
absolutely wonderful
really enjoyed it and they played with
great verve and panache
and once upon a time you report to ipsa
for your comments on wales so
are you changing your opinion or of
other free football
no i adore wales and i used to live
there it's where i began my career
it's only about there are nine people in
wales
who have had an operation to remove
their sense of humor from inside their
brains and replace it with crunched up
doritos
and the joke i made about wales
was that the land it wasn't a very funny
joke was that the language seemed to
have
too few vowels how you can report that
to the police is it's beyond me but
that's
that's another issue i mean the vast
majority of welsh people
are fine um now in terms of low lights
in the tournament who is
not impressing you who do you think
which teams do you think
look like they are you know not in the
right place right now well the fun about
this tournament for me is i'm i'm a lot
older than you
and um nine if you if you'd asked me in
1989 you'll be watching european
championships
and you'll be watching the game between
ukraine and north macedonia
i would have said who where
ukraine does the soviet union know about
this
uh does yugoslavia know about this the
number of countries in europe has kind
of doubled
since you know i i grew up with football
um
and uh i i find it fascinating to see
how they've developed as
as countries which is partly what the
diary is about it's
it's more about history and politics and
it is about football um but also how
they've
developed politically uh in a football
sense as well
uh who hasn't impressed me uh i'm
delighted to say every year i do a list
of countries
i lose i've had to put it back this year
for various reasons
um and turkey is always in the top three
um
um and i'm absolutely delighted to say
that turkey have been
hopeless in every possible respect in
the tournament so far
stubbish belligerent and useless so i've
been delighted to see that
um other other sides the checks are
better than
i'd expected them to be and we won't
find it easy playing them
[Music]
i was delighted to see the scots easily
defeated
and but live with the terror
that this will come back to haunt me
tomorrow afternoon
tomorrow evening and that they'll beat
us because
they will as the commentators keep
saying turn up
to the game which seems to be an
important thing all the commentators
seem to think it's very important that
teams turn up
um it's a remarkable
remarkable idea isn't it that this
football expertise the most important
thing you must turn up
[Music]
you